The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: Welcome to 6.851
Advanced Data Structures.
I am Erik Demaine.
You can call me Erik.
We have two TAs, Tom
Morgan and Justin Zhang.
Tom's back there.
Justin is late.
And this class is
about all kinds
of very cool data structures.
You should have already
seen basic data structures
like balance binary
search trees and things
like that, log n
time to do wherever
you want in one dimension.
And here we're going to turn
all those data structures
on their head and
consider them in all sorts
of different models and
additional cool problems.
Today we're going to talk about
time travel or temporal data
structures, where
you're manipulating time
as any good time
traveler should.
Then we'll do geometry where
we have higher dimensional
data, more than one dimension.
Then we'll look at
a problem called
dynamic optimality, which is,
is there one best binary search
tree that rules them all?
Then we'll look at something
called memory hierarchy, which
is a way to model more realistic
computers which have cache
and then more cache
and then main memory
and then dish and all
these different levels.
How do you optimize for that?
Hashing is probably the most
famous, and most popular,
most used data structure
in computer science.
We'll do a little bit on that.
Integers, when you know that
your data is integers and not
just arbitrary black boxes that
you can compare or do whatever,
you can do a lot
better with integers.
You usually beat log n time.
Often you can get constant time.
For example, if you want
to do priority queues,
you can do square
root log log n time.
That's the best
known randomized.
Dynamic graphs, you have
a graph you want to store,
and the edges are being added
and maybe deleted, like you're
representing a social network.
And people are friending
and de-friending.
You want to maintain some
interesting information
about that graph.
Strings, you have
a piece of text,
such as the entire
worldwide web.
And you want to search
for a substring.
How do you do that efficiently?
It's sort of the Google problem.
Or you searching through
DNA for patterns, whenever.
And finally succinct
data structures,
which is all about
taking what we normally
consider optimal
space or n space
and reducing it down to the very
bare minimum of bits of space.
Usually if you want
to store something
where there's 2 to
the n possibilities,
you want to get away
with n bits of space,
maybe plus square root of
n or something very tiny.
So that's the sync
data structures.
So that's an overview
of the entire class.
And these are sort of the
sections we'll be following.
Let me give you a quick
administrative overview
of what we're doing.
Requirements for the class--
I guess, first,
attending lecture.
Obviously if you
don't attend lecture,
there'll be videos online.
So that's resolvable.
But let me know if you're
not going to make it.
We're going to have problems
sets roughly every week.
If you're taking the
class for credit,
they have a very simple rule
of one page in, one page out.
This is more constraint on
us to write problems that
have easy or short answers.
You probably need
to think about them
a little bit before they're
transparent, but then easy
to write up.
And then scribing lectures--
so we have a scribe for today,
I hope.
Here?
Yes, good.
So most of the
lectures have already
been scribed in some
version, and your goal
is to revise that scribe
notes that if you don't like
handwritten notes, which
are also online, then easier
for people to read.
Let's see.
Listeners welcome.
We're going to have an
open problem session.
I really like open problems.
I really like solving
open problems.
So we've done this every time
this class has been offered.
So if you're interested in
also solving open problems,
it's optional.
I will organize-- in
a couple of weeks,
we'll have a weekly
open problem session
and try to solve
all the things that
push the frontier of
advanced data structures.
So in classes, we'll see
the state of the art.
And then we'll change the state
of the art in those sessions.
I think that's it.
Any questions about
the class before we
get into the fun stuff?
All right.
Let's do some time traveling.
Before I get to time
traveling, though, I
need to define our
model of computation.
A theme in this class is that
the model of computation you're
working with matters.
Models matter.
And there's lots of different
models of computation.
We'll see a few of the
main ones in this class.
And the starting
point, and the one
we'll be using throughout today,
is called a pointer machine.
It's an old one from the '80s.
And it corresponds to
what you might think about
if you've done a lot of
object-oriented programming,
and before that,
structure-oriented programming,
I guess.
So you have a bunch of nodes.
They have some fields in them,
a constant number of fields.
You can think of these
as objects or strucs
in c It used to be records
back in Pascal days,
so a lot of the papers
call them records.
You could just have a
constant number of fields.
You could think of
those numbered, labeled.
It doesn't really matter
because there's only
a constant number of them.
Each of the fields could be
a pointer to another node,
could be a null pointer, or
could have some data in it.
So I'll just assume that
all my data is integers.
You can have a
pointer to yourself.
You can have a pointer over
here, whatever you want.
A pointer machine would
look something like this.
In any moment, this is the
state of the pointer machine.
So you think this as the memory
of your computer storing.
And then you have
some operations
that you're allowed to do.
That's the computation
part of the model.
You can think of this
as the memory model.
What you're allowed to
do are create nodes.
You can say something
like, x equals new node.
You can, I don't
know, look at fields.
You can do x equals y.field.
You can set fields,
x.field equals y.
You can compute on these
data, so you can add 5 and 7,
do things like that.
I'm not going to worry about--
I'll just write et cetera.
This is more a model
about how everything's
organized in memory, not so
much about what you're allowed
to do to the data items.
In this lecture, it
won't matter what
you're doing to the data items.
We never touch them.
We just copy them around.
So am I missing anything?
Probably.
I guess you could destroy
nodes if you felt like it.
But we won't have
to today, because we
don't want to
throw anything away
when you're time traveling.
It's too dangerous.
And then the one catch
here is, what are x and y?
There's going to be one
node in this data structure
or in your memory
called the root node.
And you could think of that
as that's the thing you always
have in your head.
This is like your
cache, if you will.
It's just got a constant
number of things, just
like any other node.
And x and y are
fields of the root.
So that sort of
ties things down.
You're always working
relative to the root.
But you can look at the data,
basically follow this pointer,
by looking at the field.
You could set one
of these pointers--
I think I probably need
another operation here,
like x equals y.field1,
field2, that sort of thing,
and maybe the reverse.
But you can manipulate
all nodes sort
of via the root is the idea.
You follow pointers,
do whatever.
So pretty obvious,
slightly annoying
to write down formally.
But that is pointer machine.
And what we're going to
be talking about today
in time travel is
suppose someone
gives me a pointer machine
data structure, for example,
balanced binary search
tree, linked list.
A lot of data structures,
especially classic data
structures, follow
pointer machine model.
What we'd like to do is
transform that data structure
or make a new
pointer machine data
structure that does
extra cool things,
namely travel through time.
So that's what
we're going to do.
There's two senses of time
travel or temporal data
structures that we're going
to cover in this class.
The one for today is
called persistence,
where you don't forget
anything, like an elephant.
And the other one
is retroactivity.
Persistence will be today.
Retroactivity is next class.
Basically, these correspond
to two models of time travel.
Persistence is the branching
universe time travel model,
where if you make a
change in the past,
you get a new universe.
You never destroy old universes.
Retroactivity is more
like Back to the Future,
when you go back, make
a change, and then you
can return to the present
and see what happened.
This is a lot harder to do.
And we'll work on
that next class.
Persistence is what
we will do today.
So persistence.
The general idea of persistence
is to remember everything--
the general goal, I would say.
And by everything, I
mean different versions
of the data structure.
So you're doing data
structures in general.
We have update operations
and query operations.
We're mainly concerned
about updates here.
Every time you do an
update, you think of it
as taking a version of the data
structure and making a new one.
And you never want to
destroy old versions.
So even though an update
like an insert or something
changes the data structure, we
want to remember that past data
as well.
And then let's make
this reasonable.
All data structure operations
are relative to a specified
version.
So an update makes and
returns a new version.
So when you do an
insert, you specify
a version of your data
structure and the thing
you want to insert.
And the output is a new version.
So then you could insert into
that new version, keep going,
or maybe go back to the
old version, modify that.
I haven't said exactly
what's allowed here,
but this is sort of
the general goal.
And then there are four
levels of persistence
that you might want to get.
First level is called
partial persistence.
This is the easiest to obtain.
And in partial
persistence, you're
only allowed to update
the latest version, which
means the versions
are linearly ordered.
This is the easiest
to think about.
And time travel can easily get
confusing, so start simple.
We have a timeline of
various versions on it.
This is the latest.
And what we can do is
update that version.
We'll get a new version, and
then our latest is this one.
What this allows is looking back
at the past to an old version
and querying that version.
So you can still ask questions
about the old version,
if you want to be able to do
a search on any of these data
structures.
But you can't change them.
You can only change the
most recent version.
So that's nice.
It's kind of like time
machine on Mac, I guess.
If you've ever seen the
movie Deja Vu, which is not
very common, but it's
a good time travel
movie, in the first half of
the movie, all they can do
is look back at the past.
Later they discover
that actually they
have a full persistence model.
It takes a while
for dramatic effect.
In full persistence, you can
update anything you want--
so update any version.
and so then the
versions form a tree.
OK.
So in this model,
maybe you initially
have a nice line of versions.
But now if I go back to
this version and update it,
I branch, get a
new version here.
And then I might keep modifying
that version sometimes.
Any of these guys can branch.
So this is why I call it the
branching universe model, when
you update your branch.
So no version ever
gets destroyed here.
Again, you can
query all versions.
But now you can also
update any version.
But you just make a new version.
It's a totally new world.
When I update this
version, this version
knows nothing about all the--
this doesn't know
about this future.
It's created its own future.
There's no way to sort of
merge those universes together.
It's kind of sad.
That's why we have the
third level of persistence,
which lets us merge timelines.
It's great for lots
of fiction out there.
If you've seen the
old TV show Sliders,
that would be
confluent persistence.
So confluent persistence,
you can combine two versions
to create a new version.
And in this case, again, you
can't destroy old versions.
In persistence, you
never destroy versions.
So now the versions form a
DAG, directed acyclic graph.
So now we're allowing--
OK, you make some
changes, whatever.
You branch your universe,
make some changes.
And now I can say, OK, take
this version of the data
structure and this version
and recombine them.
Get a new version, and then
maybe make some more changes.
OK, what does combine mean?
Well, it depends on
your data structure.
A lot of data structures
have combine operations
like if you have linked lists,
you have two linked lists,
you can concatenate them.
That's an easy operation.
Even if you have
binary search trees,
you can concatenate
them reasonably easy
and combine it into one
big binary search tree.
So if your data structure
has an operation that
takes as input two
data structures,
then what we're saying is now
it can take two versions, which
is more general.
So I could take the
same data structure,
make some changes in
one way, separately make
some changes in a
different way, and then
try to concatenate them
or do something crazy.
This is hard to
do, and most of it
is an open problem
whether it can be done.
But I'll tell you about it.
Then there's another level
even more than confluent
persistence.
This is hard to interpret
in the time travel world,
but it would be functional
data structures.
If you've ever programmed
in a functional programming
language, it's a little bit
annoying from an algorithm's
perspective, because it
constrains you to work
in a purely functional world.
You can never modify anything.
OK.
Now, we don't want
to modify versions.
That's fine.
But in a functional
data structure,
you're not allowed to
modify any nodes ever.
All you can do is
make new notes.
This is constraining,
and you can't always
get optimal running times
in the functional world.
But if you can get a
functional data structure,
you have all these
things, because you
can't destroy anything.
If you can't destroy
nodes, then in particular,
you can't destroy versions.
And all of these things
just work for free.
And so a bunch of
special cases are known,
interesting special
cases, like search trees
you can do in the
functional world.
And that makes all
of these things easy.
So the rest of this
lecture is going
to be general techniques for
doing partial full persistence,
what we know about
confluent, and what
we know about functional,
brief overview.
Any questions about those
goals, problem definitions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm still confused
about functional, because--
ERIK DEMAINE: What
does functional mean?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, I
guess you'll see what--
functional looks like all
the other things, I agree.
You'll see in a moment
how we actually implement
partial and persistence.
We're going to be
changing nodes a lot.
As long as we still
represent the same data
in the old versions, we
don't have to represent it
in the same way.
That lets us do things
more efficiently.
Whereas in functional,
you have to represent
all the old versions
in exactly the way
you used to represent them.
Here we can kind of
mangle things around
and it makes things faster.
Yeah, good question.
So it seems almost the same,
but it's nodes versus versions.
I haven't really
defined a version.
But it's just that all the
queries answer the same way.
That's what you need
for persistence.
Other questions?
All right.
Well, let's do some
real data structures.
We start with
partial persistence.
This is the easiest.
For both partial and
full persistence,
there is the following result.
Any pointer machine data
structure, one catch with a
constant number of pointers
to any node--
so this is constant n degree.
In a pointer machine, you
always have a constant number
of pointers out
of a node at most.
But for this result
to hold, we also
need a constant number of
pointers into any node.
So this is an extra constraint.
Can be transformed into
another data structure that
is partially persistent and does
all the things it used to do--
so I'll just say, can be
made partially persistent.
You have to pay something, but
you have to pay very little--
constant amortized
factor overhead,
multiplicative overhead
and constant amount
of additive space per change
in the data structure.
So every time you do a
modification in your pointer
machine-- you set one of
the fields to something--
you have to store that forever.
So, I mean, this is the
best you could hope to do.
You've got to store
everything that happened.
You pay a constant
factor overhead, eh.
We're theoreticians.
That doesn't matter.
Then you get any data
structure in this world
can be made
partially persistent.
That's nice.
Let's prove it.
OK, the idea is pretty simple.
Pointer machines are all
about nodes and fields.
So we just need to simulate
whatever the data structure is
doing to those nodes
and fields in a way
that we don't lose
all the information
and we can still
search it very quickly.
First idea is to
store back pointers.
And this is why we need the
constant n degree constraint.
So if we have a node--
how do I want to
draw a node here?
So maybe these are the
three fields of the node.
I want to also store
some back pointers.
Whenever there is a node
that points to this node,
I want to have a
back pointer that
points back so I know where
all the pointers came from.
If there's only p pointers,
then this is fine.
There'll be p fields here.
So still constant, still in
the pointier machine model.
OK, I'm going to need
some other stuff too.
So this is a simple thing,
definitely want this.
Because if my nodes
ever move around,
I've got to update
the pointers to them.
And where are those pointers?
Well, the back pointers
tell you where they are.
Nodes will still
be constant size,
remain in pointer
machine data structure.
OK.
That's idea one.
Idea two is this part.
This is going to store
something called mods.
It could stand for something,
but I'll leave it as mods.
So these are two of the
fields of the data structure.
Ah, one convenience here
is for back pointers,
I'm only going to store it for
the latest version of the data
structure.
Sorry.
I forgot about that.
We'll come back to that later.
And then the idea is to
store these modifications.
How many modifications?
Let's say up to p, twice p.
p was the bound on the
n degree of a node.
So I'm going to allow 2p
modifications over here.
And what's a
modification look like?
It's going to consist
of three things--
get them in the right order--
the version in which
something was changed,
the field that got changed,
and the value it go changed to.
So the idea is that these
are the fields here.
We're not going to touch those.
Once they're set to something--
or, I mean, whatever
they are initially,
they will stay that way.
And so instead of actually
changing things like the data
structure normally
would, we're just
going to add modifications
here to say, oh,
well at this time, this field
changed to the value of 5.
And then later on, it
changed to the value 7.
And then later on, this one
changed to the value 23,
whatever.
So that's what
they'll look like.
There's a limit to how many--
we can only store a constant
number of mods to each node.
And our constant will be 2p.
OK.
Those are the
ideas, and now it's
just a matter of
making this all work
and analyzing that it's
constant amortized overhead.
So first thing is if you
want to read a field,
how would I read a field?
This is really easy.
First you look at what the
field is in the node itself.
But then it might
have been changed.
And so remember when
I say read the field,
I actually mean while
I'm given some version,
v, I want to know what is the
value of this field at version
v, because I want to be able
to look at any of the old data
structures too.
So this would be at
version v. I just
look through all
the modifications.
There's constantly many,
so it takes constant time
to just flip through them
and say, well, what changes
have happened up to version v?
So I look at mods
with version less than
or equal to v. That will be all
the changes that happened up
to this point.
I see, did this field change?
I look at the latest one.
That will be how I read
the field of the node, so
constant time.
There's lots of ways to make
this efficient in practice.
But for our purposes,
it doesn't matter.
It's constant.
The hard part is how
do you change a field?
Because there might not be
any room in the mod structure.
So to modify, say we want to
set node.field equal to x.
What we do is first
we check, is there
any space in the mod structure?
If there's any blank mods,
so if the node is not full,
we just add a mod.
So a mod will look
like now field x.
Just throw that in there.
Because right at this moment--
so we maintain a time
counter, just increment
it ever time we do a change.
This field changed that value.
So that's the easy case.
The trouble, of course,
is if the node is full--
the moment you've
all been waiting for.
So what we're going to do
here is make a new node.
We've ran out of space.
So we need to make a new node.
We're not going to touch the old
node, just going to let it sit.
It still maintains all
those old versions.
Now we want a new node
that represents the latest
and greatest of this node.
OK.
So make a new node.
I'll call it node prime to
distinguish from node, where
with all the mods, and this
modification in particular,
applied.
OK, so we make a new
version of this node.
It's going to have some
different fields, whatever
was the latest version
represented by those mods.
It's still going to
have back pointers,
so we have to maintain
all those back pointers.
And now the mod,
initially, is going
to be empty, because we
just applied them all.
So this new node doesn't
have any recent mods.
Old node represents
the old versions.
This node is going to
represent the new versions.
What's wrong with this picture?
AUDIENCE: Update pointers.
ERIK DEMAINE: Update pointers.
Yeah, there's pointers
to the old version
of the node, which are fine for
the old versions of the data
structure.
But for the latest version
of the data structure,
this node has moved
to this new location.
So if there are any old
pointers to that node,
we've got to update them
in the current version.
We have to update them to
point to this node instead.
The old versions are fine, but
the new version is in trouble.
Other questions or
all the same answer?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you wanted
to read an old version
but you just have the
new version, [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: OK--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: The
question is essentially,
how do we hold on to versions?
Essentially, you can think of
a version of the data structure
as where the root node is.
That's probably the easiest.
I mean, in general, we're
representing versions
by a number, v. But we
always start at the root.
And so you've given
the data structure,
which is represented
by the root node.
And you say, search
for the value 5.
Is it in this binary
search tree or whatever?
And then you just start
navigating from the root,
but you know I'm inversion
a million or whatever.
I know what version
I'm looking for.
So you start with the root,
which never changes, let's say.
And then you follow
pointers that
essentially tell
you for that version
where you should be going.
I guess at the root version,
it's a little trickier.
You probably want a little array
that says for this version,
here's the root node.
But that's a special case.
Yeah.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: So on the
new node that you
created, the fields that you
copied, you also have to have
a version for them, right?
Because [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: These--
AUDIENCE: Or do you
version the whole node?
ERIK DEMAINE: Here we're
versioning the whole node.
The original field
values represent
what was originally there,
whenever this node was created.
Then the mods specify what
time the fields change.
So I don't think
we need times here.
All right.
So we've got to update
two kinds of pointers.
There's regular
pointers, which live
in the fields, which are
things pointing to the node.
But then there's
also back pointers.
Because if this is
a pointer to a node,
then there'll be a back
pointer back to the node.
And all of those have to change.
Conveniently, the back
pointers are easy.
So if they're back
pointers to the node,
we change them to
the node prime.
How do we find
the back pointers?
Well, we just follow
all the pointers
and then there will be
back pointers there.
Because I said we're
only maintaining
backed pointers for
the latest version,
I don't need to preserve
the old versions
of those backed pointers.
So I just go in
and I change them.
It takes constant time,
because the constant number
of things I point to, each
one as a back pointer.
So this is cheap.
There's no persistence here.
That's an advantage of
partial persistence.
The hard part is
updating the pointers
because those live in fields.
I need to remember the old
versions of those fields.
And that we do recursively.
Because to change
those pointers,
that's a field update.
That's something
exactly of this form.
So that's the same operation
but on a different node.
So I just do that.
I claim this is good.
That's the end of the algorithm.
Now we need to analyze it.
How do we analyze it?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: Amortize it.
ERIK DEMAINE: Amortized
analysis, exactly
the answer I was looking for.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE] amortization.
The most powerful
technique in amortization
is probably the
potential method.
So we're going to use that.
There's a sort of more--
you'll see a charging
argument in a moment.
We want the potential function
to represent when this data
structure is in a bad state.
Intuitively, it's in a bad state
when a lot of nodes are full.
Because then as soon as
you make a change in them,
they will burst, and you have
to do all this crazy recursion
and stuff.
This case is nice and cheap.
We just add a modification,
constant time.
This case, not so nice
because we recurse.
And then that's going
to cause more recursions
and all sorts of
chaos could happen.
So there's probably a few
different potential functions
that would work here.
And an old version
of these nodes I said
should be the number
of full nodes.
But I think we can make
life a little bit easier
by the following.
Basically, the total
number of modifications--
not quite the total,
almost the total.
So I'm going to do c times
the sum of the number of mods
in latest version nodes.
OK.
So because we sort
of really only
care about-- we're only
changing the latest version,
so I really only
care about nodes that
live in the latest version.
What do I mean by this?
Well, when I made
this new node prime,
this becomes the new
representation of that node.
The old version is dead.
We will never change it again.
If we're modifying, we will
never even look at it again.
Because now everything
points to here.
So I don't really
care about that node.
It's got a ton of mods.
But what's nice is that when
I create this new node, now
the mod list is empty.
So I start from scratch,
just like reinstalling
your operating system.
It's a good feeling.
And so the potential goes down
by, I guess, c times 2 times p.
When I do this change, potential
goes down by basically p.
AUDIENCE: Is c any constant or--
ERIK DEMAINE: c will be a
constant to be determined.
I mean, it could be 1.
It depends how you
want to define it.
I'm going to use the CLRS
notion of amortized cost, which
is actual cost plus
change in potential.
And then I need a
constant here, because I'm
measuring a running time versus
some combinatorial quantity.
So this will be to match the
running time that we'll get to.
OK.
So what is amortized cost?
There's sort of two
cases modification.
There's the cheap case
and the not so cheap case.
In general, amortized cost--
in both cases, it's
going to be at most--
well, first of all, we
do some constant work
just to figure out all this
stuff, make copies, whatever.
So that's some constant time.
That's the part that I don't
want to try to measure.
Then potentially,
we add a new mod.
If we add a mod, that
increases the potential by c.
Because we're just counting
mods, multiplying by c.
So we might get plus 1 mod.
This is going to
be an upper bound.
We don't always add 1, but
worst case, we always had 1,
let's say.
And then there's
this annoying part.
And this might happen,
might not happen.
So then there's a plus maybe.
If this happens, we
decrease the potential
because we empty out the
mods for that node in terms
of the latest version.
So then we get a negative
2cp, change in potential.
And then we'd have to pay
I guess up to p recursions.
Because we have to--
how many pointers
are there to me?
Well, at most p of them, because
there are at most p pointers
to any node.
OK.
This is kind of a weird--
it's not exactly algebra here.
I have this thing, recursions.
But if you think about
how this would expand,
all right, this
is constant time.
That's good.
And then if we do this--
I'll put a question mark here.
It might be here.
It might not.
If it's not here, find constant.
If it is here, then this gets
expanded into this thing.
It's a weird way to
write a recurrence.
But we get p times whatever
is in this right hand side.
OK.
But then there's this minus 2cp.
So we're going to
get p times 2c here.
That's the initial cost.
So that will cancel with this.
And then we might get
another recursion.
But every time we get a
recursion, all the terms
cancel.
So it doesn't matter
whether this is here or not.
You get 0, which is great.
And you're left with
the original 2c.
Constant.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE] potential functions
are always a little crazy.
What's happening here is
that, OK, maybe you add a mod.
That's cheap.
But when we have to do this
work and we have to do this
recursion-- this is up to
2p updates or recursions--
we are charging it to the
emptying of this node.
The number of mods
went from 2p down to 0.
And so we're just
charging this update cost
to that modification.
So if you like charging schemes,
this is much more intuitive.
But with charging schemes,
it's always a little careful.
You have to make sure
you're not double charging.
Here it's obvious that
Kind of a cool and magical.
This is a paper by
Driscoll, Sarnak, Sleator,
Tarjan from 1989.
So it's very early
days of amortization.
But they knew how to do it.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: What happens
if you overflow the root?
Yeah, I never thought about
the root before today.
But I think the way
to fix the root is
just you have one big table
that says, for a given version--
I guess a simple
way would be to say,
not only is a version
a number, but it's also
a pointer to the root.
There we go.
Pointer machine.
So that way you're just
always explicitly maintaining
the root copy or the pointer.
Because otherwise,
you're in trouble.
AUDIENCE: Then can you
go back to [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: So in order
to refer to an old version,
you have to have the
pointer to that root node.
If you want to do it just
from a version number,
look at the data structure.
Just from a version
number, you would
need some kind of
lookup table, which
is outside the pointer machine.
So you could do it
in a real computer,
but a pointer machine is
not technically allowed.
So it's slightly awkward.
No arrays are allowed
in pointer machines,
in case that wasn't clear.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] constant
space to store for [INAUDIBLE].
And also, what if we have
really big numbers [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: In this model,
in the pointer machine model,
we're assuming that whatever
the data is in the items
take constant space each.
If you want to know about
bigger things in here,
then refer to future lectures.
This is time travel, after all.
Just go to a future
class and then come back.
[LAUGHS] So we'll get
there, but right now,
we're not thinking
about what's in here.
Whatever big thing
you're trying to store,
you reduce it down to
constant size things.
And then you spread them around
nodes of a pointer machine.
How you do that, that's
up to the data structure.
We're just transforming the
data structure to be persistent.
OK, you could ask about other
models than pointer machines,
but we're going to stick
to pointer machines here.
All right.
That was partial persistence.
Let's do full persistence.
That was too easy.
Same paper does
full persistence.
Systems That was just a warm up.
Full persistence is actually
not that much harder.
So let me tell you
basically what changes.
There are two issues.
One is that everything here
has to change and not by much.
We're still going to
use back pointers.
We're still going
to have my mods.
The number of mods is going
to be slightly different
but basically the same.
Back pointers no longer just
refer to the latest version.
We have to maintain back
pointers in all versions.
So that's annoying.
But hey, that's life.
The amortization, the
potential function
will change slightly
but basically not much.
Sort of the bigger issue you
might first wonder about,
and it's actually the most
challenging technically,
is versions are
no longer numbers.
Because it's not a line.
Versions are nodes in a tree.
You should probably
call them vertices
in a tree to distinguish them
from nodes in the pointer
machine.
OK, so you've got
this tree of versions.
And then versions are just
some point on that tree.
This is annoying
because we like lines.
We don't like trees as much.
So what we're going to
do is linearize the tree.
Like, when in doubt, cheat.
How do we do this?
With tree traversal.
Imagine I'm going to draw
a super complicated tree
of versions.
Say there are three versions.
OK.
I don't want to number
them, because that would be
kind of begging the question.
So let's just call
them x, y, and z.
All right.
I mean, it's a directed
tree, because we
have the older versions.
This is like the
original version.
And we made a change.
We made a different change
on the same version.
What I'd like to do is a
traversal of that tree,
like a regular, as if you're
going to sort those nodes.
Actually, let me use
color, high def here.
So here's our
traversal of the tree.
And I want to look at the
first and the last time I
visit each node.
So here's the first
time I visit x.
So I'll write this is
the beginning of x.
Capital X. Then this is
the first time I visit y,
so it's beginning of y.
And then this is the last time
I visit y, so it's the end of y.
And then, don't care.
Then this is the beginning of z.
And this is the end of z.
And then this is the end x.
If I write those sequentially,
I get bxbyeybzez,
because this is so easy, ex.
OK, you can think of these
as parentheses, right?
For whatever reason I chose b
and e for beginning and ending,
but this is like open
parens, close parens.
This is easy to
do in linear time.
I think you all know how.
Except it's not
a static problem.
Versions are changing
all the time.
We're adding versions.
We're never deleting
versions, but we're always
adding stuff to here.
It's a little
awkward, but the idea
is I want to
maintain this order,
maintain the begin and
the end of each you
might say subtree of versions.
This string, from
bx to ex, represents
all of the stuff in x's
subtree, in the rooted tree
starting at x.
How do I maintain that?
Using a data structure.
So we're going to use something,
a data structure we haven't yet
seen.
It will be in lecture 8.
This is a time travel
data structure,
so I'm allowed to do that.
So order maintenance
data structure.
You can think of this as
a magical linked list.
Let me tell you what the
magical linked list can do.
You can insert--
I'm going to call it
an item, because node
would be kind of confusing
given where we are right now.
You can insert a new item in
the list immediately before
or after a given item.
OK.
This is like a
regular linked list.
Here's a regular linked list.
And if I'm given a particular
item like this one,
I can say, well, insert
a new item right here.
You say, OK.
Fine.
I'll just make a new node and
relink here, relink there.
Constant time, right?
So in an order maintenance
data structure,
you can do this
in constant time.
Wow!
So amazing.
OK, catch is the second
operation you can do.
Maybe I'll number these.
This is the update.
Then there's the query.
The query is, what
is the relative order
of two notes, of two items?
x and y.
So now I give you this
node and this node.
And I say, which is to the left?
Which is earlier in the order?
I want to know, is x
basically less than y
in terms of the
order in the list?
Or is y less than x?
And an order maintenance
data structure
can do this in constant time.
Now it doesn't look like your
mother's linked list, I guess.
It's not the link list
you learned in school.
It's a magical linked
list that can somehow
answer these queries.
How?
Go to lecture 7.
OK.
Forward reference,
lecture 8, sorry.
For now, we're just going to
assume that this magical data
structure exists.
So in constant
time, this is great.
Because if we're maintaining
these b's and e's, we
want to maintain the order
that these things appear in.
If we want to create
a new version,
like suppose we were
just creating version z,
well, it used to be everything
without this bz, ez.
And we'd just insert two
items in here, bz and ez.
They're right next
to each other.
And if we were given version
x, we could just say,
oh, we'll look at ex and insert
two items right before it.
Or you can put them
right after bx.
I mean, there's no
actual order here.
So it could have been y first
and then z or z first and then
y.
So it's really easy to add a
new version in constant time.
You just do two of
these insert operations.
And now you have this magical
order operation, which
if I'm given two versions--
I don't know, v and w--
and I want to know is
v an ancestor of w,
now I can do it
in constant time.
So this lets me do a third
operation, which is, is version
v an ancestor of version w?
Because that's going to
be true if and only if bv
is an ev nest around bw and ew.
OK.
So that's just three tests.
They're probably not
all even necessary.
This one always holds.
But if these guys fit in between
these guys, then you know--
now, what this tells us,
what we care about here,
is reading fields.
When we read a field,
we said, oh, we'll
apply all the modifications
that apply to version
v. Before that, that
was a linear order.
So it's just all versions
less than or equal to v. Now
it's all versions that are
ancestors of v. Given a mod,
we need to know, does this
mod apply to my version?
And now I tell you, I can
do that in constant time
through magic.
I just test these
order relations.
If they hold, then that
mod applies to my version.
So w's the version
we're testing.
v is some version in the mod.
And I want to know, am
descendant of that version?
If so, the mod applies.
And I update what the field is.
I can do all pairwise ancestor
checks and figure out,
what is the most recent
version in my ancestor history
that modified a given field?
That lets me read a
field in constant time.
Constants are getting
kind of big at this point,
but it can be done.
Clear?
A little bit of
a black box here.
But now we've gotten
as far as reading.
And we don't need
to change much else.
So this is good news
Maybe I'll give you
a bit of a diff.
So full persistence,
fully persistent theorem--
done.
OK.
Same theorem just
with full persistence.
How do we do it?
We store back pointers
now for all versions.
It's a little bit annoying.
But how many mods do we use?
There's lots of ways
to get this to work,
but I'm going to
change this number
to 2 times d plus p plus 1.
Wait, what's d? d is the
number of fields here.
OK.
We said it was
constant number fields.
I never said what that constant
is. d for out degree, I guess.
So p is in degree, max in
degree. d is max out degree.
So just slightly more--
that main reason for this
is because back pointers now
are treated like everyone else.
We have to treat both the out
pointers and the in pointers
as basically the same.
So instead of p,
we have d plus p.
And there's a plus
1 just for safety.
It gets my amortization
to work, hopefully.
OK.
Not much else-- this
page is all the same.
Mods are still, you give
versions, fields, values,
reading.
OK, well, this is no longer
less than or equal to v. But
this is now with a version, sort
of the nearest version, that's
an ancestor of v.
That's what we were
just talking about.
So that can be done
in constant time.
Check it for all of
them, constant work.
OK.
That was the first part.
Now we get to the hard
part, which is modification.
This is going to be different.
Maybe you I should just erase--
yeah, I think I'll
erase everything,
except the first clause.
OK.
If a node is not
full, we'll just
add a mod, just like before.
What changes is
when a node is full.
Here we have to do something
completely different.
Why?
Because if we just
make a new version
of this node that has empty
mods, this one's still full.
And I can keep modifying
the same version.
This new node that I just erased
represents some new version.
But if I keep modifying
an old version, which
I can do in full persistence,
this node keeps being full.
And I keep paying
potentially huge cost.
If all the nodes were full,
and when I make this change
every node gets
copied, and then I
make a change to
the same version,
every node gets copied again.
This is going to take
linear time per operation.
So I can't do the old strategy.
I need to somehow make
this node less full.
This is where we're
definitely not functional.
None of this was
functional, but now I'm
going to change an old node, not
just make a new one in a more
drastic way.
Before I was adding a mod.
That's not a
functional operation.
Now I'm actually going to remove
mods from a node to rebalance.
So what I'd like to do is
split the node into two halves.
OK.
So I had some big
node that was--
I'll draw it-- completely full.
Now I'm going to make two nodes.
Here we go.
This one is going
to be half full.
This one's going to
be half full of mods.
OK.
The only question left is, what
do I do with all these things?
Basically what I'd like
to do is have the--
on the one hand, I want
to have the old node.
It's just where it used to be.
I've just removed half of
the mods, the second half,
the later half.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
Figure it out.
It's linearized.
I haven't thought
deeply about that.
Now we're going to make a
new node with the second half
of the mods.
It's more painful
than I thought.
In reality, these mods represent
a tree of modifications.
And what you need to do is
find a partition of that tree
into two roughly equal halves.
You can actually do a
one third, 2/3 split.
That's also in a future lecture,
which whose number I forget.
So really, you're
splitting this tree
into two roughly
balanced halves.
And so this 2 might actually
need to change to a 3,
but it's a constant.
OK.
What I want is for
this to represent
a subtree of versions.
Let me draw the picture.
So here's a tree of versions
represented by the old mods.
I'd like to cut out a
subtree rooted at some node.
So let's just assume
for now this has exactly
half the nodes.
And this has half the nodes.
In reality, I think it
can be one third, 2/3.
OK.
But let's keep it convenient.
So I want the new
node to represent
this subtree and this node
to represent everything else.
This node is as if this
stuff hasn't happened yet.
I mean, so it represents all
these old versions that do not,
that are not in the subtree.
This represents all
the latest stuff.
So what I'm going to
do is like before, I
want to apply some
mods to these fields.
And whatever minds were
relevant at this point, whatever
had been applied, I apply
those to the fields here.
And so that means I can
remove all of these mods.
I only cared about these ones.
Update these fields accordingly.
I still have the other mods to
represent all the other changes
that could be in that subtree.
OK.
So we actually split the tree,
and we apply mods to new nodes.
Anything else I need to say?
Oh, now we need to
update pointers.
That's always the fun part.
Let's go over here.
So old node hasn't moved.
But this new node has moved.
So for all of these
versions, I want
to change the pointer that
used to point to old node
should now point to new node.
In this version, it's fine.
It should still
point to old node,
because this represents
all those old versions.
But for the new version,
that version in the subtree,
I've got to point here instead.
OK.
So how many pointers could
there be to this node
that need to change.
That's a tricky part
in this analysis.
Think about it for a while.
I mean, in this
new node, whatever
is pointed to by either here or
here in the new node also has
a return pointer.
All pointers are bidirectional.
So we don't really care
about whether they're forward
or backward.
How many pointers
are there here?
Well, there's d here
and there's p here.
But then there's also
some additional pointers
represented over here.
How many?
Well, if we assume this
magical 50/50 split,
there's right now d plus p plus
1 mods over here, half of them.
Each of them might be a pointer
to some other place, which
has a return pointer
in that version.
So number of back pointers
that we need to update
is going to be this, 2
times d 2 times p plus 1.
So recursively update at
most 2 times d plus 2 times p
plus 1 pointers to the node.
The good news is this is
really only half of them
or some fraction of them.
It used to be--
well, there were
more pointers before.
We don't have to
deal with these ones.
That's where we're
saving, and that's
why this amortization works.
Let me give you a potential
function that makes this work--
is minus c times sum of the
number of empty mod slots.
It's kind of the same
potential but before
we had this notion of
dead and alive nodes.
Now everything's alive
because everything
could change at any moment.
So instead, I'm going to
measure how much room I have
in each node.
Before I had no
room in this node.
Now I have half the
space in both nodes.
So that's good news.
Whenever we have
this recursion, we
can charge it to a
potential decrease.
Fee goes down by--
because I have a
negative sign here--
c times, oh man, 2 times
d plus p plus 1, I think.
Because there's d plus
p plus 1 space here,
d plus p plus 1 space here.
I mean, we added
one whole new node.
And total capacity
of a node in mods
is 2 times d plus p plus 1.
So we get that times c.
And this is basically
just enough,
because this is 2 times
d plus 2 times p plus 2.
And here we have a plus 1.
And so the recursion gets
annihilated by 2 times d plus
2 times p plus 1.
And then there's one
c left over to absorb
whatever constant cost there
was to do all this other work.
So I got the constants
just to work,
except that I cheated and it's
really a one third, 2/3 split.
So probably all of these
constants have to change,
such is life.
But I think you get the idea.
Any questions about
full persistence?
This is fun stuff, time travel.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in the first
half of the thing where
the if, there's room
you can put it in.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about how
we represent the version.
Because before when we said
restore now [INAUDIBLE].
It made more sense if now was
like a timestamp or something.
ERIK DEMAINE: OK.
Right, so how do we represent a
version even here or anywhere?
When we do a modification, an
update, in the data structure,
we want to return
the new version.
Basically, we're going
to actually store
the DAG of versions.
And a version is going to
be represented by a pointer
into this DAG.
One of the nodes in this
DAG becomes a version.
Every node in this DAG is
going to store a pointer
to the corresponding b character
and a corresponding e character
in this data
structure, which then
lets you do anything you want.
Then you can query
against that version,
whether it's an ancestor
of another version.
So yeah, I didn't mention that.
Versions are nodes in here.
Nodes in here have pointers
to the b's and e's.
And vice versa, the b's
and e's have pointers back
to the corresponding
version node.
And then you can keep
track of everything.
Good question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] question.
Remind me what d is in this.
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, d was
the maximum out degree.
It's the number of fields in
a node, as defined right here.
Other questions?
Whew.
OK, a little breather.
That was partial persistence,
full persistence.
This is, unfortunately, the
end of the really good results.
As long as we have
constant degree nodes,
in and out degree,
we can do all.
We can do for
persistence for free.
Obviously there are practical
constants involved here.
But in theory, you
can do this perfectly.
Before we go on to
confluence, there
is one positive result,
which is what if you
don't like amortize bounds.
There are various reasons
amortize bounds might not
be good.
Maybe you really care
about every operation
being no slower than it was
except by a constant factor.
We're amortizing here, so some
operations get really slow.
But the others are all
fast to compensate.
You can deamortize, it's called.
You can get constant
worst case slowdown
for partial persistence.
This is a result of Garret
Brodle from the late '90s, '97.
For full persistence--
so it's an open problem.
I don't know if people
have worked on that.
All right.
So some, mostly good results.
Let's move on to confluent
persistence where things
get a lot more challenging.
Lots of things go out the window
with confluent persistence.
In particular, your
versions are now a DAG.
It's a lot harder
to linearize a DAG.
Trees are not that
far from pads.
But DAGs are quite far
from pads, unfortunately.
But that's not all
that goes wrong.
Let me first tell you the
kind of end effect as a user.
Imagine you have
a data structure.
Think of it as a
list, I guess, which
is a list of characters
in your document.
You're using vi or Word,
your favorite, whatever.
It's a text editor.
You've got a string of words.
And now you like to do
things like copy and paste.
It's a nice operation.
So you select an interval of
the string and you copy it.
And then you paste
it somewhere else.
So now you've got two
copies of that string.
This is, in some
sense, what you might
call a confluent
operation, because--
yeah, maybe a cleaner way to
think of it is the following.
You have your string.
Now I have an operation,
which is split it.
So now I have two strings.
OK.
And now I have an operation,
which is split it.
Now I have three strings.
OK.
Now I have an operation
which is concatenate.
So I can, for
example, reconstruct
the original string-- actually,
I have the original string.
No biggie.
Let's say-- because
I have all versions.
I never lose them.
So now instead, I'm going to
cut the string here, let's say.
So now I have this and this.
And now I can do
things like concatenate
from here to here to here.
And I will get this
plus this plus this.
OK.
This guy moved here.
So that's a copy/paste
operation with a constant number
of splits and concatenates.
I could also do cut and paste.
With confluence, I can
do crazy cuts and pastes
in all sorts of ways.
So what?
Well, the so what
is I can actually
double the size of
my data structure
in a constant number
of operations.
I can take, for example,
the entire string
and concatenate it to itself.
That will double the
number of characters,
number of elements in there.
I can do that again
and again and again.
So in u updates,
I can potentially
get a data structure
size 2 to the u.
Kind of nifty.
I think this is why
confluence is cool.
It's also why it's hard.
So not a big surprise.
But, here we go.
In that case, the version DAG,
for reference, looks like this.
You're taking the same
version, combining it.
So here I'm assuming I have
a concatenate operation.
And so the effect here,
every time I do this,
I double the size.
All right.
What do I want to say about
confluent persistence?
All right.
Let me start with the
most general result, which
is by Fiat and Kaplan in 2003.
They define a notion called
effective depth of a version.
Let me just write it down.
It's kind of like
if you took this DAG
and expanded it out to be a
tree of all possible paths.
Instead of point
to the same node,
you could just
duplicate that node
and then have pointers
left and right.
OK.
So if I did that, of course,
this size grows exponentially.
It explicitly represents the
size of my data structure.
At the bottom, if
I have u things,
I'm going to have 2 to the
u leaves at the bottom.
But then I can easily
measure the number of paths
from the root to
the same version.
At the bottom, I still
label it, oh, those
are all v. They're all the
same version down there.
So exponential number
of paths, if I take log,
I get what I call
effective depth.
It's like if you somehow
could rebalance that tree,
this is the best you
could hope to do.
It's not really a lower bound.
But it's a number.
It's a thing.
OK.
Then the result they achieve
is that the overhead is
log the number of
updates plus-- this
is a multiplicative overhead,
so you take your running time.
You multiply it by this.
And this is a time
and a space overhead.
So maximum effective depth
of all versions, maybe even
sum of effective depths, but
we'll just say max to be safe.
Sorry-- sum over
all the operations.
This is per operation.
You pay basically
the effective depth
of that operation as a factor.
Now, the annoying thing is if
you have this kind of set up
where the size
grew exponentially,
then number of paths
is exponential.
Log of the number of
paths is linear in u.
And so this factor could be
as much as u, linear slowdown.
Now, Fiat and Kaplan argue
linear slowdown is not
that bad, because if you weren't
even persistent, if you did
this in the naive way of
just recopying the data,
you were actually spending
exponential time to build
the final data structure.
It has exponential size.
Just to represent it explicitly
requires exponential time,
so losing a linear
factor to do u operations
and now u squared time
instead of 2 to the u.
So it's a big
improvement to do this.
The downside of this approach is
that even if you have a version
DAG that looks like this,
even if the size of the data
structure is staying
normal, staying linear, so
this potential, you could
be doubling the size.
But we don't know what
this merge operation is.
Maybe it just throws
away one of the versions
or does something--
somehow takes half
the nodes from one
side, half the nodes from
the other side maybe.
These operations
do preserve size.
Then there's no great reason why
it should be a linear slowdown,
but it is.
OK?
So it's all right but not great.
And it's the best
general result we know.
They also prove a lower bound.
So lower bound is some effect
of depth, total bits of space.
OK.
What does this mean?
So even if this
is not happening,
the number of bits
of space you need
in the worst case--
this does not
apply to every data structure.
That's one catch.
They give a specific
data structure
where you need this much space.
So it's similar to
this kind of picture.
We'll go into the details.
And you need this much space.
Now, this is kind of
bad, because if there's
u operations, and each of these
is u, that's u squared space.
So we actually need a
factor u blow up in space.
It looks like.
But to be more precise,
what this means is
that you need omega e of
v space, and therefore
time overhead per update, if--
this is not written
in the paper--
queries are free.
Implicit here, they just want
to slow down and increase space
for the updates you do,
which is pretty natural.
Normally you think of queries
as not increasing space.
But in order to construct
this lower bound,
they actually do
this many queries.
So they do e of v queries
and then one update.
And they say, oh well, space
had to go up by an extra e of v.
So if you only charge
updates for the space,
then yes, you have
to lose potentially
a linear factor, this effect
of death, potentially u.
But if you also
charge the queries,
it's still constant
in their example.
So open question, for
confluent persistence,
can you achieve
constant everything?
Constant time and
space overheads,
multiplicative
factor per operation,
both updates and queries.
So if you charge the
queries, potentially you
could get constant everything.
This is a relatively
new realization.
And no one knows
how to do this yet.
Nice challenge.
I think maybe we'll work on that
in our first problem session.
I would like to.
Questions about that result?
I'm not going to
prove the result.
But it is a fancy
rebalancing of those kinds
of pictures to get this log.
There are other results
I'd like to tell you about.
So brand new result--
that was from 2003.
This is from 2012--
no, '11, '11, sorry.
It's SOTO, which is in January,
so it's a little confusing.
Is it '11?
Maybe '12.
Actually now I'm not sure.
It's February already, right?
A January, either this
year or last year.
It's not as general
a transformation.
It's only going to hold in
what's called a disjoint case.
But it gets a very good bound--
not quite constant,
but logarithmic.
OK, logarithmic
would also be nice.
Or log, log n, whatever n is.
Pick your favorite n,
number of operations, say.
OK.
If you assume that confluent
operations are performed only
on two versions with
no shared nodes--
OK, this would be a way to
forbid this kind of behavior
where I concatenate the
data structure with itself.
All the nodes are common.
If I guarantee that maybe I, you
know, slice this up, slice it,
dice it, wherever, and
then re-emerge them
in some other order, but
I never use two copies
of the same piece, that
would be a valid confluent
operation over here.
This is quite a
strong restriction
that you're not allowed.
If you try to, who
knows what happens.
Behavior's undefined.
So won't tell you,
oh, those two versions
have this node in common.
You've got to make
a second copy of it.
So somehow you have to guarantee
that control and operations
never overlap.
But they can be reordered.
Then you can get
order log n overhead.
n is the number of operations.
I have a sketch
of a proof of this
but not very much
time to talk about it.
All right.
Let me give you a quick picture.
In general, the
versions form a DAG.
But if you make this assumption,
and you look at a single node,
and look at all the versions
where that node appears,
that is a tree.
Because you're not allowed
to remerge versions
that have the same node.
So while the big
picture is a DAG,
the small picture of a
single guy is some tree.
I'm drawing all
these wiggly lines
because there are all
these versions where
the node isn't changing.
This is the entire version DAG.
And then some of these nodes--
some of these versions,
I should say--
that node that we're
thinking about changes.
OK, whenever it
branches, it's probably
because the actual
node changed, maybe.
I don't know.
Anyway there are some dots
here where the version changed,
some of the leaves,
maybe, that changed.
Maybe some of them haven't yet.
In fact, let's see.
Here where it's change, it could
be that we destroyed the node.
Maybe it's gone from the
actual data structure.
But there still may
be versions down here.
It's not really a tree.
It's a whole DAG of
stuff down there.
So that's kind of ugly.
Where never the
node still exists,
I guess that is an
actual leaf of the DAG.
So those are OK.
But as soon as I maybe
delete that node,
then there can be a
whole subtree down there.
OK.
So now if you look at
an arbitrary version,
so what we're thinking about
is how to implement reading,
let's say.
Reading and writing are
more or less the same.
I give you a version.
I give you a node, and
I give you a field.
I want to know, what is the
value of that field, that node,
that version?
So now where could
a version fall?
Well it has to be
in this subtree.
Because the node has to exist.
And then it's maybe a pointer.
A pointer could be to
another node, which
also has this kind of picture.
They could be overlapping trees.
In general, there
are three cases.
Either you're lucky, and the
version you're talking about
is a version where
the node was changed.
In that case, the data is
just stored right there.
That's easy.
So you could just say, oh,
how did the node change?
Oh, that's what the field is.
OK, follow the pointer.
A slightly harder
case it's a version
in between two such changes.
And maybe these are not updates.
So I sort of want to know, what
was the previous version where
this node changed
in constant time?
It can be done.
Not constant time,
actually, logarithmic time,
using a data structure
called link-cut trees,
another fun black
box for now, which
we will cover in lecture
19, far in the future.
OK.
Well, that's one case.
There's also the version
where maybe a version
is down here in a subtree.
I guess then the
node didn't exist.
Well, all these
things can happen.
And that's even harder.
It's messy.
They use another trick, which
is called fractional cascading,
which I'm not even going to
try to describe what it means.
But it's got a very cool name.
Because we'll be
covering it in lecture 3.
So stay tuned for that.
I'm not going to say how
it applies to this setting,
but it's a necessary
step in here.
In the remaining
zero minutes, let
me tell you a little bit about
functional data structures.
[LAUGHTER]
Beauty of time travel.
Functional-- I just
want to give you
some examples of things that
can be done functionally.
There's a whole book about
functional data structures
by Okasaki.
It's pretty cool.
A simple example
is balanced BSTs.
So if you just want to get
log n time for everything,
you can do that functionally.
It's actually really easy.
You pick your favorite balance
BST, like red black trees.
You implement it top down so you
never follow parent pointers.
So you don't need
parent pointers.
So then as you make changes
down the tree, you just copy.
It's called path copying.
Whenever you're about
to make a change,
make a copy of that node.
So you end up copying all
the change nodes and all
their ancestors.
There's only log n of them,
so it takes log n time.
Clear?
Easy.
It's a nice technique.
Sometimes path copying
is very useful.
Like link-cut
trees, for example,
can be made functional.
We don't know what they are,
but they're basically a BST.
And you can make
them functional.
We use that in a paper.
All right.
Deques.
These are doubly ended queues.
So it's like a stack and
a queue and everything.
You can insert and delete from
the beginning and the end.
People start to know
what these are now,
because Python calls him that.
But you can also
do concatenation
with deques in constant
time per operation.
This is cool.
Deques are not very
hard to make functional.
But you can do deques and
you can concatenate them
like we were doing in the figure
that's right behind this board.
Constant time split
is a little harder.
That's actually one
of my open problems.
Can you do lists with split and
concatenate in constant time--
functionally or confluently,
persistently, or whatever?
Another example-- oh, you
can do a mix of the two.
You can get log n search in
constant time deque operations,
is you can do tries.
So a try is a tree
with a fixed topology.
Think of it as a directory tree.
So maybe you're
using Subversion.
Subversion has time
travel operations.
You can copy an entire
subtree from one version
and stick it into a new
version, another version.
So you get a version DAG.
It's a confluently
persistent data structure--
not implemented optimally,
because we don't necessarily
know how.
But there is one paper.
This actually came from the open
problem section of this class
four years ago, I think.
It's with Eric Price
and Stefan Langerman.
You can get very good results.
I won't write them down
because it takes a while.
Basically log the degree
of the nodes factor
and get functional, and
you can be even fancier
and get slightly better
bounds like log log the degree
and get confluently persistent
with various tricks,
including using all of
these data structures.
So if you want to implement
subversion optimally,
that is known how to be done but
hasn't actually been done yet.
Because there are those
pesky constant factors.
I think that's all.
What is known about functional
is there's a log n separation.
You can be log n
away from the best.
That's the worst
separation known,
between functional and just
a regular old data structure.
It'd be nice to improve that.
Lots of open problems here.
Maybe we'll work
on them next time.